MALE SPEAKER: Good afternoon,
and welcome to Google
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Today, we are joined
by John Palfrey, who's
with us to discuss his
latest book, "Bibliotech: Why
Libraries Matter More Than
Ever in the Age of Google."
In "Bibliotech," Palfrey
investigates the purpose
in future libraries, when
information is broadly
available on the internet.
In addition to
"Bibliotech," Palfrey
is the author of
several books, including
"Born Digital" and "Interop."
He's the head of the school
Phillips Andover Academy.
Previously, at Harvard,
he led the effort
to reorganize the Harvard
Law School Library,
and he's the founding member
of the Digital Public Library
of America.
Please join me in
welcoming John Palfrey.
JOHN PALFREY: Thank you all for
making time on this busy day.
And Brendan, thank you
for organizing this
and for inviting me here
to Google in Cambridge.
I am thrilled to have a chance
to talk about this new book
called "Bibliotech."
Its subtitle, in fact, is
"Why Libraries Matter More
Than Ever in the
Age of Google" so I
feel it's fitting to be making
this particular argument here
at Google.
And since it came out
just two days ago,
I'm thrilled to be
doing it right here
for the first official
book talk with all of you.
And I hope that especially
if I say anything
that's inappropriate or
provocative about what you're
up to that you will push
back and ask the questions
in the conversational part.
On some level, this book
is really a love letter
to libraries and to librarians.
It's an argument that says that
we need these institutions more
than ever at this
moment in our history.
Not despite what all of you are
doing at Google, but in part,
because of it.
And to try to make the argument
that both physical libraries as
well as digital
forms of libraries
are crucial to our democracy.
That's the entire
argument right there.
I'm not burying the lead.
Just putting it out there.
And I will then try to make
that argument in the course
of the next 20 or so minutes.
The inspiration, in
a way, for this book
was I worked down the
street at Harvard Law School
for a long time and was the
director of its library--
the law library-- which
is, in many respects,
the largest and biggest
law library in the world.
And one of the items in the
collection is this image.
I doubt you'll be able
to guess what it is,
but it's the personal library of
Oliver Wendell Holmes jr., who
was on the Supreme Court.
He was also a professor
at our law school.
And this picture
actually depicts
his library-- is
personal library--
in Washington, DC, when he was
on the United States Supreme
Court.
And often, I think about
this particular picture
because it seems like such a
lovely place to sit and think
and to do your work.
But of course, it's also,
perhaps, anachronistic,
particularly with kids
who are growing up
in this particular age.
I work now at a boarding
school-- Andover.
And I'm grateful to have a
few of our fine graduates
here and Google staff
members as well.
And if you think
about the kids--
AUDIENCE: And fellow
Exeter graduates.
JOHN PALFREY: Oh my gosh.
All right.
Fellow Exeter graduates, too.
We're a purple room between
the red and the blue.
But if you think about the
kids who are educating today--
and I also have
small kids-- you can
imagine that this particular
vision of what a room might
be like with all of
these books around it
might not be exactly that
they have in mind as a space
to work.
When I worked at the
Harvard Law School Library,
we had a beautiful reading room.
And it was full almost
all the time with kids
to elbow to elbow.
And as they were
working in there,
and they were almost always
doing what some of you
are doing.
They had a laptop.
They had a water or
coffee or something.
But almost never did they
do something like this
to actually pull a book
down off the shelves.
They were actually
in the space, I
think, to be with one
another in a social space.
And they wanted to
be in the library.
They wanted the reference
librarians and so forth.
But the act was not doing this.
They weren't walking
around to the shelves
and pulling something off.
So the thought
experiment, in a way,
is what's a version of
this thoughtful space
that we will create for
kids who are growing up now,
even if they don't
necessarily associate
this kind of a library with
the way in which they want
to be connecting with ideas.
Now, I suspect that
many people will
continue to build
libraries like this one.
But it will almost be books as
furniture or collectible items
or something that are
there as tangible items
as opposed to the
references they will get to.
But I think it's very important
that we actually come up
with an affirmative
version of what
we think would be a great space
for learning and for studying.
But also note the importance
of the physical library
and the continuing
importance of that.
Because we're here
in Cambridge, I've
got a picture up of the
Boston Public Library.
So the history of
libraries, I think,
is a very important
piece of the story.
In 1852, a philanthropist
named Joshua Bates
agreed to give $50,000
to the city of Boston
to create the first big public
library actually in the world.
And the idea of having a space
where anybody in the city
can come free to
all to get access
to information or knowledge
seemed radical at the time,
even though now it seems
completely obvious.
But it actually
started here in Boston
in a really meaningful way.
And I think the most
important part of this image
is the notion of free
to all-- the idea
that anybody can get access
to information at any time
without anybody else
making that choice for us.
I think that's a cornerstone
piece of democracy.
And just like that reading
room that I showed from Holmes,
what will the physical library
be like in a digital era.
I think it goes without saying
that part of the backdrop
here is the notion of knowledge
moving to the cloud-- the idea
that the vast majority
of time, instead
of going like this to pull
down a book, kids go like this
and pull something up.
Ordinarily, going on
their Android device right
to their Google browser
and typing it in
and finding the information
that has been stored up here.
And this is one of the ways in
which the book is in a sense,
although not directly, it's
concerned with the notion
that the people who are
holding the information
are in the private sector.
And that includes
you guys and it
includes lots of others who are
the holders of information when
it's in the cloud-based
environment.
There isn't really
a public option
when it comes to the
cloud at the moment--
at least not one that's
a significant player
in the field.
And actually that is one
of the arguments, which
is to think about how
do we ensure that there
is a public option in addition
to the private spaces that
are developing online?
I think it becomes most acute
in the context of books.
Over the last several
years, librarians
have been fretting greatly about
the future of their ability
to be libraries in
that classic way
that the Boston Public Library
and other places have been.
Why?
In part, because as
knowledge moves to the cloud
and to the extent
that people continue
to prefer ebooks or
electronic forms of things
over the analog forms
of things, it actually
becomes trickier for
libraries to do what
they have done traditionally.
I'm just curious, actually,
because I'm doing this
at each of the talks.
How many people prefer to
read a physical form of a book
like this in this room?
Little more than half.
How many people
prefer a digital book?
How many people are
really agnostic?
You're happy to read
either, which includes me.
Yes, sir?
Another option?
AUDIENCE: I would like to
point out the other option.
Mine is would love to read it
in paper, don't want to carry
the paper.
JOHN PALFREY: Awesome.
And so there therefore
you download it
to a Kindle or some other
device, whatever it might.
iBooks.
AUDIENCE: Android phone.
JOHN PALFREY: Android phone.
Oh, right.
Excellent, excellent.
What is the--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] just poor
functionality on many ebooks
that are badly transformed.
JOHN PALFREY: Right
I don't think anybody
has really cracked that
code, particularly,
nor made it more useful.
One of the very
interesting things
is actually in the context of
law school, these unbelievably
expensive books-- $150
books that kids use still
for their case books--
they're full of cases
that are in the public domain.
They're materials that
you could get anywhere.
And yet we have not yet
gone to digital case books.
How is that possible
given the enormous cost.
If you're in law
school, you're taking
a handful of classes.
$150 each for these books.
Almost no uptake for
the digital books.
I think it is the
interface is no better.
The annotation is
terrible and so forth.
And it just seems to me
that's a fairly obvious thing.
But let's just
imagine for a second
that we all trend toward-- at
least for some of our usage--
toward preferring a digital
format that's actually
excellent and can be
accessed through an Android
phone or otherwise very easily.
One of the problems is
that publishers have not
been willing,
traditionally, to allow
libraries to lend
on the same basis
that they have in the past.
Many of the publishers
have said no.
Even with our most
popular books,
we won't lend them
at all to libraries
or allow a license
in the libraries
to allow them to lend.
But if you think that
even more fundamentally,
even if the publishers
do allow libraries to do,
what's happened is
that there's been
a fundamental change in what
libraries are actually doing,
which is in the current age,
they but a physical book
like this.
And they put it on the shelf
and they have it accessible,
and if you are living in
Arlington or Watertown
and your library doesn't have
it, they can call Cambridge.
And Cambridge can send it
along with interlibrary loan
and so forth.
In the digital era, that
isn't necessarily true.
And by and large, the contracts
that libraries are getting
do not allow them
ultimately to own
the book in any physical way.
They're just leasing
or loaning them.
If the publisher goes out a
business, that's one problem.
If the library stops
paying the license,
that's another problem.
But fundamentally, libraries do
not then own their collections
in the digital world.
And that has as much
to do with contract
as it does with the
background copyright law.
But the notion is
that librarians
are fearful that
they will not be
able to fulfill the
function they have fulfilled
in democracies in a
digital era as they
have in the analog era,
which itself is just
a perverse outcome.
We should have more access
to knowledge and information,
not less.
And yet the way in
which it is playing out
doesn't make that likely.
So I think at this
moment where we
stand is we have a
moment where we're
going to build the future.
We'll build the
future of libraries
and of knowledge and
information in a way that's
akin to building the great
public libraries from 150 years
ago or so.
This is a view of the
Boston Public Library
as it was being built. And I
think we're at a similar moment
when it comes to
thinking about the hybrid
of digital and analog libraries.
I think we are at
a design moment
where it's crucial that we
figure out what we actually
want this information or this
Knowledge Commons to look like.
And then we actually
do it in the way
that we have in the past.
If you are imagining
building a new building--
and this is a side
elevation of the building
I worked in at
Harvard Law School--
you would in fact bring
together architects, presumably,
with the teachers and
librarians and maybe
some of the students
you're trying to consultant
and build the space for.
And you would do a process.
Maybe it's a design charrette.
But you would come
up with an idea.
What should the
classrooms look like?
What should the library reading
rooms look like and so forth?
And I feel like
that's the moment
that we have right
now in libraries
is to do that for
a digital era--
to bring together people,
like all of you who
work in the information
space and information
architects, along with
physical architects
and figure out what does
this hybrid environment look
like going forward?
And how can we make sure that
it has all of the excitement
and innovation of the
information economy
while also having a preservation
for knowledge in the long run
and also those democratic ideals
of access of being free to all?
And I think it's entirely
possible to do that.
The case that I
make in this book
is that one of the
things we should
do in addition to supporting
traditional libraries
is actually work together to
create a digital public library
system.
Just as we did 150 years
ago, create a system--
funded by Mr. Carnegie and
others-- of little libraries
all around the world.
The United States
being one part of it,
but the same notion
has spread globally.
We should be building digital
libraries at the same time.
I understand, of
course, that many
of the early efforts
in this space
happen right here for
Google and Google Books.
Did anybody work on
Google Books or does?
Awesome.
So we have some veterans or
current members of the team.
The inspiration of the
Google Books project
led a bunch of people to
come into a room in Harvard
about four years ago to seek
to do something complementary,
which was to create, actually,
a digital public library
system for the country, to
take advantage of the ability
to digitize enormous
amounts of works
and make them available
in a broad way.
And that actually has been going
for the last several years.
It started with
a single sentence
that was agreed to by a
series of law professors,
to begin with, but also
librarians and information
architects and some
foundation presidents.
And the idea was to create an
open and distributed network
of online resources drawn
from all over the country
in order to create the
backbone, the platform,
for a digital library
system for the future.
And amazingly enough, we've
been working on doing that.
And it is a part
of the argument I
want to make for the
future of libraries.
So one way to think
about this, actually,
is to step back and
say, what actually
is a library in a digital age?
What is essential about it?
What are the pieces of it?
And I think that they are
slightly different than they
were in the analog age.
If you start with
the idea of code,
I actually think
libraries are, in fact,
in a digital space about code.
It is my strong preference that
that could be open source code
and made available very broadly.
So one of the
efforts in creating
a digital public
library, I think,
is the creation of a
GitHub for libraries--
the notion of creating
a huge amount of code
that anybody can take and
reuse in a variety of ways.
We started by
offering to the world
the chance to code
anything you wanted
and to put it into a
common environment.
This was called a beta sprint.
And it actually
attracted about 50 people
who came forward
to build what they
thought a digital public
library ought to look like.
We required,
amazingly, that they
retain no intellectual
property rights--
that they agree to give those
rights to the public domain--
and that they get no
compensation for it.
And the amazing thing was that
people stepped up and wanted
to do this.
Because there's a huge reservoir
of interest in creating
a digital future for libraries.
So as we have built the
digital public library,
it has come with a
series of releases
and ultimately been a
technical project to start.
Second, libraries
are about metadata.
They are about the data that
describe where the data are.
So if you think about a
book as a bunch of data,
you have a huge amount
of metadata about it.
I don't have to make that
case here in this room.
But it is an essential piece
of what libraries hold.
So a catalog record would be an
example of that-- circulation
records, who was it who wanted
that material, what its subject
headings are, and so forth.
And secondly, if you think about
what a library needs to have,
it needs to have this
huge store metadata.
Libraries spend a huge
amount of time and money
creating often duplicative
versions of metadata.
And often they also worry
about the intellectual property
claims of this, that maybe
there are copyright interests
in the metadata.
I would submit
that there actually
aren't good copyright claims
for most forms of metadata.
And in fact, if libraries
were much more collaborative
in terms of sharing
their metadata,
there would be many, many fewer
forms of duplicative effort.
And ultimately, part of
this digital library system
is a huge store of metadata.
There's something called
Library Cloud, which
is one experiment in this way.
And the DPLA is a part of that.
AUDIENCE: So isn't OCLC
supposed to do that?
JOHN PALFREY: I think
OCLC should do that
and should do that
in a more open way.
And there are lots
of ways if those
who are holding information in
a fairly proprietary fashion
would in fact share
it more broadly,
we would reduce a lot
of duplicative effort.
So yes, I think if
OCLC were in essence
to create all of
it's information
on an open access basis,
we will be better off.
Individual institutions
have been saying back
to OCLC-- which is a great
collaborative and a very
important thing-- if you
were to allow us to do this,
we would be able
to have something
that a huge amount of innovation
could be done on top of.
And I think that's actually
starting to happen.
Third, the digital library
is itself about content,
of course.
And I think one
of the big efforts
is to do what Google Books has
done but to do it in a highly
distributed way, which is, in
fact, to digitize as much as we
can that is enormously useful.
Of course, there are
intellectual property topics
that arise in this
context, as you well know.
But I actually think
there's much more that we
could be doing than we are.
So the third part of what
a digital library could be
is in fact the
objects themselves
and to figure out how to harness
all the digitization that is
happening all around the world.
Fourth, I think libraries are in
fact about tools and services.
They are about ways
of getting information
to people who wish to use
them and to engage with them.
And very often, libraries
are creating the same thing
over and over again.
You might think
about each library
creating a separate Android
app rather than having
a series of open code that
they could use and reuse
in a simple format.
Another example is
the idea that we
have been working with
about having a "scanebago"--
the idea that librarians
could get a Winnebago
and put a scanner
in the back and have
maybe a retired librarian
or a library student
drive the Winnebago
around a community,
go into places like
historical societies,
and digitize materials
and share the more broadly
with the world.
This is an idea that
has lots of antecedents.
So in Massachusetts, there's
something called the Digital
Commonwealth, an effort that
allows all of the 351 cities
and towns to digitize their
materials at the Boston Public
Library.
You can imagine the distributed
network that is possible
if you were in a sense
to be spreading out
across the country
and digitizing
materials and bringing them
together into a common place.
And last, I think
libraries are fundamentally
about human beings.
They are about the librarians.
They are about
the people who are
the interface
between the library
users and the information.
And even though
this is something,
of course, that Google does
extremely well in the search
business, we also
know particularly
from studying people's search
patterns that it is crucial.
You have humans who can be
an interface between a kid
and information.
I'm teaching a course in
the United States history
at a high school I work at.
This is the third year.
You all probably
took History 300.
And at the end of it, you
write a very long paper.
If students relied
only upon what
they could find on the
web, I can guarantee you
that it would be a much
less good paper, in fact,
than the ones that are done
when human librarians are
part of that interface.
And I think that
may be something
that over time
could be conquered
throughout algorithms,
but no time soon.
And it's quite clear
that librarians
as human guides within the
information environment
often digitally-- but in
addition to the analog--
are crucial.
So that is the fifth element
of what a library needs to be.
So one way to think about
it in more technical terms
is to think of
libraries not so much as
standalone institutions--
institutions
that are collecting information
often in a competitive way.
In other words, trying to
collect the same information
into each of these
different physical spaces.
Think instead of
libraries as platforms--
as platforms that enable
people to do things
with information
and with knowledge.
So the design that we've created
for this Digital Public Library
is, in fact, to
create exactly that.
So in very simple
form, it's really
a collection of
metadata about objects
that are around
the world that have
been curated in various
ways related to America.
That's in this
metadata repository.
There's a mechanism
for ingesting it.
So the notion is that there
are many different contributors
of information into this
particular platform.
And on top of it, an open API
is a crucial part of the design.
And on the far end
is a mode of export--
a mode of export that
says if anybody wants
to take all of this code, all
of this metadata, anything
that we've created, and create
a better one, you can do that.
The notion that
if somebody wanted
to create something that
would take literally
all of this effort and make it
a competitor that is vastly more
effective, I actually think
that would be a huge success
if it were to happen.
Fundamentally, I think the we
will create in this digital era
things that we
can't imagine today.
But there also is a
need, I think, for a way
to access information that is
in all of the libraries that
are collected.
So the Digital Public
Library has a front end--
it's DPLA if you
want to go to it.
It is a reasonably
simple interface.
I think it works OK in terms
of presenting information.
But most important, I
think, it directs you
to the various applications and
the other ways in which people
have thought about
creating access
to the same store
of information.
And I would love
to see libraries
across the country and
archives and museums taking
the same information
and curating it
for their local communities--
a very different way
to think about
their job, which is
to go into an enormous store of
information that's been curated
at a national level, but
then think about how it's
made available
directly to individuals
in a local environment.
Another piece of building it out
is thinking about the sources--
how do you get the information
into such a platform?
And I think this
is, in part, why
the system can be so
effectively distributed broadly.
The notion is to create a
series of different hubs
that are digitizing materials
and then sharing them
with others through the on
ramp that is the Digital Public
Library of America.
There are a couple
different types of hubs.
One is being called
a service hub
that really is often a state.
So in Massachusetts, it's
the Digital Commonwealth.
So at the Boston Public
Library are a handful
of people who work very
effectively at digitizing
materials and then ensuring
that they're available locally
and then shared globally.
And there are a series of
different states that have it.
There are also content hubs.
These are places
that have digitized
a huge amount of information.
So an example would
be Harvard University
down the street or New
York Public Library,
which has contributed about
a million objects to at.
Google Books could
be a great example.
We would love to
have contributions
from that project in the DPLA.
But the notion is you have
large stores of information that
have been digitized
at big institutions
and then you have states that
create places for individuals
to share the information
up into this library.
Roughly speaking,
as of today, these
are places that have
already contributed
into this national
store of information.
It is about a third
of the country.
And the effort right now
over the next couple years
is to complete
the map, to ensure
that every part of
the country has a way
to contribute this information
into the digital store that
will be available.
And then of course, the
value of it, the power of it
becomes much, much greater.
So if you look on
the map, you can
see the ones that are orange
red are the service hubs up
and running.
There are a bunch
in development.
And the yellow dots
are representative
of big institutions that
are contributing information
from libraries, from
archives, and from museums.
And again, we'd be very
happy to have private sector
partners in that effort.
In a slightly more
technical mode,
this is the notion of
the platform itself.
I would say that one piece
that we have not focused on
as well as we might and
where should Google engineers
wish to be helpful or
designers is really
on the user interface side.
Again, anybody could
take the information
and could create an
application that would
make it more useful to others.
The notion of the platform
is that libraries ultimately
should be in this
business, should
be focused on making information
more useful to users.
Actually, one of my great
fears about libraries becoming
obsolete, in a sense,
is if the interfaces
are ones that never
have libraries
in the first set
of search results.
So if you think about the
patterns the graduate students
or the students who are
trying to access information
go through, they almost
always start with you guys--
with Google.
And they will look in
the search results,
and they will often
click on, for instance,
Wikipedia as one of
the early entrants.
They might click on Amazon
and find a work there.
They might click on a
recommendation for Amazon.
But I actually think libraries
have often found themselves out
of that particular mix.
And I feel like as
information moves increasingly
to the cloud,
librarians actually
need to be in that research
and development space.
They need to be
creating applications
that ensure that in
that search process,
libraries are a part of the
relevant search results.
And I think if the emphasis
were in part on developing
applications that were
useful in that process,
I think that could happen.
And hopefully through
this design, it might.
One particular example of
the kinds of things libraries
have developed.
This is a version
called Stack View.
This was created at the
Harvard Law School Library
through a group called the
library innovation lab.
And the idea went this way.
It was to think
about the process
of browsing in the stacks.
If you think about the thing
that people usually tell you
they love about libraries,
it's that experience
of getting a call number and
then walking into some stacks
and trying to find a book.
And then you see the book
there, but you actually
see other books
you want around it.
Because that's part of
the fun of libraries.
And you come out
with a huge number
of books in your arms
from the stacks--
many more books often
than you can carry.
And the fear is that if what
happens in the digital age
is you simply
search for something
and you find exactly what
you want in a pinpoint way,
you might lose that
form of serendipity.
You may have heard
the same critique
about the newspaper moving
from the physical newspaper
to the online space that if
you're reading the New York
Times in the morning, you often
see an article you didn't think
you needed off to the right.
I'm sure you think
about this a lot
in the context of presenting
material in Google.
But it seemed to me
another way to see
this is to flip it around and
say as much as we can worry
about the loss of serendipity
and the loss of stacks--
and to be very
clear, I think stacks
are a great thing and
a very important part
of the interface in libraries.
And we ought to have them.
I actually think it's
possible that in a digital age
we could do better than we
do in the physical space.
So I'll give you one example.
The Harvard libraries,
which are, in effect,
down the street.
Or you could think about
the MIT libraries closer by.
They actually don't have
a single stack where you
can find all the information.
In the context of Harvard, there
are 73 different libraries.
And In fact, there's a library
depository 20 miles away.
And the notion that
anybody could actually
look at a stack of things and
see where all the books are
is implausible for
most library systems.
Think about it.
How could we combine the MIT
library system and the Harvard
library system?
Or think about metro
New York and how many
different libraries there are.
But digitally, of
course, we can do that.
And we could do that,
in fact, much better.
And the idea here
of Stack View is
to say what if you
combined entire collections
and then had basically
an infinite stack
you could go through.
You could imagine paging
along in your Android device
and seeing this infinite
stack presented.
And then if you
could imagine, also,
using all that metadata
that we've created and made
accessible to fuse other
ways to surface things
that might be interesting.
So in this particular
example, somebody
has come along in a search
for "Gravity's Rainbow."
And what they see is, of
course, the "Gravity's Rainbow"
they went for.
But they've also got
a whole bunch of data
that I think has
been well anonymized
at this point from 2009
in a circulation heat map.
And the idea is to say who
in fact has been accessing
these works based on some
of their demographics,
and which works have
been read to the most.
You could imagine the
context of searching for,
say, "The Iliad."
Which version of a whole bunch
of editions of "The Iliad"
should you access?
And if you are a
student who wants
to know how many times
a professor has taken
that particular translation or
that particular forward, you
could use the metadata to
figure out which example
you wanted to take.
Use this just as one example to
say I think that in the future
we have so many
different ways that we
could improve upon the
information and knowledge
architecture that we've
created, but only if we create
this platform and only if
we engage libraries as well
as individuals in doing that.
Another thing that happens
if we think about libraries
in this highly
collaborative way is also
that we surface huge amounts of
really interesting information
that has been
curated very locally
and not actually yet digitized--
not yet accessible in a Google
search because it hasn't
yet been put onto the grid.
And in a very short
while, these are
a few of the things
that have been digitized
as part of this effort to
create the national on ramp
and add them into
what a library is.
And many of the
things are regional.
So tiny little
examples, for instance,
of Appalachian culture.
But also things that are
broadly of interest--
by and large things around war.
Civil War, World War
I, World War II--
these are things that
have enormous appeal.
Geology would be
another example.
Ultimately, I think we are at a
very early stage of developing
what digital libraries will be.
And importantly, they
need to be combined
with the physical library
infrastructure that we have.
And I think that's
part of what's
exciting is to say
how do we actually
think about the problems that
need solving in communities?
How do we then combine what
we can do incredibly well
in the digital environment with
what libraries do so crucially
in the physical world
and put them together
as we are building this future?
I often think about the most
beautiful of the library spaces
as we're imagining
what we could build.
This is the Adam's
Library nearby in Quincy.
And the appeal of
this in some respects
is those beautiful
reference books
that are out on this
table and the idea
that people would come to a
physical space we would come
to find the nuggets
of information
that they have been missing.
And I don't think
actually that reference
is something that's
ever going to return
to physical spaces
like libraries.
And I think that's something
that we can safely say
has been conquered by Google
and Wikipedia and others.
So I doubt people
are going to come
for these huge books
that are encyclopedias
to a particular space.
But I do think the idea,
the joy of actually coming
to a physical space in a
community to access information
that we need for one reason
or another is something
we could and should preserve.
And trying to figure out
what is something just
as beautiful as this that
actually would attract people
to come together in
a cultural setting,
I think that is a huge part
of the challenge of ensuring
that libraries thrive
in a digital era.
I think it needs to be
done in a global context.
I actually think this is one of
the huge upsides for libraries
in the digital era-- the
notion that we actually
can imagine connecting a lot
of different things together.
There's a guy named
Siva Vaidhyanathan who
wrote a book called "A
Googlization of Everything"
you may have read.
And in the end of his book,
Siva wrote about the notion
that you could imagine a
global digital library--
something that
connects the knowledge
of the world in the way a
digital library of Alexandria
might.
And in that book,
I think he presents
a really compelling vision.
And it's something
that I don't think
has to happen in just a
one size fits all way.
I think ultimately we can
create this kind of future
also by doing it locally, by
drawing upon the distributed
nature of the web,
and actually learning
from the way in which the web
was built in order to create
this global vision.
So I'm very excited
about the notion
that individually, communities--
and it could be communities
at the state level
or communities
at the national level--
can create things and then
make them interoperable.
So as we've created this Digital
Public Library of America,
part of our argument
has been to say,
we don't have to have
something exactly the same
in every one of the 200 or
so countries in the world.
But rather, just make them
interoperate effectively.
So the very first thing we
did, even as it was just
getting started, was
to have an agreement
with the European
version called Europeana.
And so through a memorandum
of understanding,
there is in fact
a series of cross
walks that allow
you as a user to go
through the information
that's in Europeana
through to the things that
are in the Digital Public
Library of America.
And the easy way
to think about this
is you can curate exhibits
in a digital away.
So the first exhibit was
to look at immigration
between the old world and
the new and vice versa.
To imagine curating
materials from both sides.
So just as these little
national digital libraries
start popping up, I
don't think the point
is we have to create one huge
digital library of Alexandria.
I think we just have to
agree on a series of things--
really dry things like metadata
standards and licensing
agreements and so forth.
But I actually think
by doing that, we
can create something
that's enormously
powerful on a global level.
Ultimately, I think it is not
going to be a utopian future.
I don't think there's
the possibility
that by just designing it well,
we'll have something completely
perfect.
Copyright completely
stands in the way
of doing what I
would want to do.
So I acknowledge this
huge elephant in the room.
If we could have a more
friendly copyright statute,
that would be very,
very helpful to creating
something that
would be approaching
a utopian future for libraries.
But we don't, so part
of it would be advocacy.
But I do actually
think it's worth
thinking in these
very broad terms,
thinking in utopian
terms, thinking
about what we want a library
to be in a digital era.
And I think by
doing that, we will
draw upon what's so
essential about libraries
in the physical area.
We will create some
things that is,
in effect, a very,
very powerful hybrid.
And I think it's something
that can be done.
Essentially, it needs to be
done in a collaborative manner,
though.
I think this is
one of the things
that libraries have done well
in the context of something
like OCLC, which used
to be a collaboration
within some libraries in
Ohio but now a very important
national collaboration.
So libraries do it often
in a very good way.
Interlibrary Loan would
be another example.
But I think too
often, still, there's
competition between
individual libraries
and there's often too much
competition between the public
and the private sector.
And my argument would
be the best approach
would be one where we
actually were doing this
in collaboration-- that
a company like Google
would work with
libraries to do it
rather than to have a
standalone series of projects
in the private sector and a
in the public sector.
So I'm a big believer that
this is something that actually
could be good for the
public in a broad way
if we were to embrace a
series of common principles.
And I would say just by way
of closing that I actually
think that this
is a project that
is enormously important to
the success of our democracy.
And this may seem
like an overstatement,
but I think that if we were
to lose physical libraries
or we were to lose the
possibility of creating
a series of digital
interfaces and objects
and really an innovative
future that lies ahead of us
that we will be much poorer
than we would be otherwise.
And I think if we get it right,
we can be much the richer.
I think it can be a very
powerful aspect of democracy
moving forward if we
get this platform right
and if we get the design and
essence of digital libraries
going forward.
And I actually think it will
not undercut local libraries.
I think it will drive people
back into physical libraries
and be a very powerful
force for good.
Thank you so much.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm a great
lover-- is this working?
I'm a great lover of libraries--
the Academy Library at Exeter,
a fantastic building.
JOHN PALFREY: It's
an amazing building.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
less interesting,
but lots of good stuff in there.
Widener-- I love looking
at the stacks and so on.
What worries me a little
bit is that your talk
seems to be based on existing
ways that libraries work.
So the notion of the
book as the unit.
The notion of metadata rather
than content being shared.
So metadata is wonderful.
I use it a lot.
The notion of metadata-- if
you look at the library rules,
they say you're
not allowed to have
more than, whatever
the number is,
five library cards per book.
So you have an author card, a
title card, and three subject
cards, which is absurd.
We don't need that kind
of restriction anymore.
But on the other hand,
the economics of libraries
depend on some of
these characteristics
to like you have to
buy a physical book.
And first sale doctrine
says once you buy it,
you can do whatever
you want with it.
But now, if you could distribute
it instantaneously anywhere
in the world, that model no
longer works economically.
Who's going to pay for
the author, the publisher?
So the economics seem to be
missing from your proposal.
How is this actually going
to fit into the publishing
ecosystem?
I think I should stop there.
I have lots of stuff because
I'm fascinated by this topic.
But I'll stop there.
JOHN PALFREY: That's good.
Well, I'm imagining from
the nature of your questions
that we agree quite violently
in terms of where we need to go.
And I don't promise
in any way to have
all of the aspects of a
huge proposal for the future
of libraries figured out.
In fact, that's sort of
essential to this story is
to say one of the
things I don't want
to do is foreclose
what might be possible.
I haven't figured out what
the right interfaces are
going to be.
I haven't figured out
what the right business
models are going to be.
But I do think that if we create
something that allows people
to build together, I
think that's something
that will result in really
great experimentation.
So when you talk about
metadata, I couldn't agree more.
I think the series of
rules that constrain
what counts as metadata
is really a potentially
destructive thing.
I think the fact that
there's so much more
in the form of metadata-- maybe
I'm using a word that itself
is too restrictive,
so you might help me
there-- restraints libraries
from doing some of things
that they could in terms of
making the knowledge much more
accessible.
You talk about the content
being restricted to the codex.
I don't think so at all.
I do think that is
a fear for libraries
that by focusing only on one or
a series a particular formats,
that's constraining.
So I think when I talk
about content, maybe, again,
I need a better word.
But the point is I think we
should break down the units
and change the units enormously.
I just don't think
libraries themselves
as institutions
are very involved
in that particular game.
So the vast majority of
people who work in libraries
are focused on acquiring
things that look like this
and bringing them
to a physical space
and helping people find them.
When I was working at the
Harvard Law School Library,
I had an early
conversation where
we looked at what
everybody was doing out
of the 100 or so people who
were there who were awesome.
And when you looked at all their
job descriptions, more or less,
99.5 of the 100 we're
focused on something that
related to the physical object.
And there was really
0.5 of somebody
who is focused on
the web interface
and the digital interface,
through which lots of people
are coming.
Then I went and talked to
a lot of the students who
were involved and
the faculty members,
and it looked like
about 50% of the time
they were walking through
the physical front door
and doing something
with objects.
And about 50% of the time they
were coming through that web
interface-- our
digital front door.
We're completely
misaligned in that way.
And I think libraries
need to be more engaged
in basically that redesign of
what that interface looks like.
And your last point about the
business models-- figuring out
something with publishers
for ebooks and everything
that will come after I think
is an essential part of it.
So most recently, the
Digital Public Library
along with President
Obama and New York Public
and a whole pile of publishers
came to an agreement
to distribute children's books
as a starting point-- a way
to think about this.
I agree with you.
There are a series of
different business models
that would be very helpful.
Alternative
compensation mechanisms
for authors and publishers
that could ensure the publisher
still gets adequately
paid, but ultimately
without needing all of
those warehouses and all
that printing time and all
those things that happen.
I actually think there
might be another model that
will work very well and will
compensate authors fairly
for what they've created.
So I think there's a huge
amount of opportunity
in exactly what
you're saying, which
is break down a
bunch of these units
and then rebuild it
in an interesting way.
I guess what I am
fundamentally saying
is let's do so in a way
that actually preserves
a public option and has a
really good role for libraries
because I think that's
going to persist.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JOHN PALFREY: Thank you.
An awesome multi-part,
impossible-to-answer question,
but just great.
AUDIENCE: That was only 10%.
JOHN PALFREY: I bet.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I've seen a trend with
libraries locking away
their rarest works.
For example, Harvard has
the original manuscripts
of Emily Dickinson, and
you can't get at them.
The only format that
they're available in
is the format
that's been edited,
and they say, well, this is
establishing a new copyright.
So even though the originals
are in the public domain,
the edited version isn't.
This seems harmful
to getting things
in the hands of the public
and disseminating information.
How do we show them that there
is an error in their way?
Or are they actually right and
they should be locking away
these rarest-of-rare works.
JOHN PALFREY:
Well, I don't think
anything should be
locked away that is
useful in public discourse.
So I can't imagine a
version which I would
say it's right to lock it away.
I think it should be
digitized and made available
in a whole variety
of ways that are
useful to humanity and to the
furthering of scholarship.
So absolutely at that level.
The Emily Dickinson archive
is a very interesting example
because as you probably
know, the works are
held in multiple institutions.
So Amherst has a bunch
and Harvard has a bunch
and so forth.
And they are actually
one of the things that
has been digitized,
in part, and shared
through this particular
system-- the Digital Public
Library of America system.
I agree with you.
I think it actually is
inappropriate and crass
to assert a new
copyright in works
associated with a great
19th-century author.
I think there's no
value in doing that.
I think that the
institutions like Harvard
and others who hold
these materials in trust
do so in the public
interest and therefore
ought to make them
freely available.
I think there is
an advocacy role.
I think librarians themselves
have been fantastic
advocates on things like
copyright and on privacy.
And actually, as a law
professor working in that area,
I would often be going to
a conference or an event
or something and librarians
were the first people
at the beginning of the line
making these great arguments.
I can't imagine what
the downside is.
I think sometimes
the argument that I
hear is that we have
these unique materials
and someday there will be a
future business model that
will allow us to rest a
little bit of profit out of it
and that will pay for
all these other things.
I don't know.
That future business
model objection
doesn't make a whole
lot of sense to me.
I've never really heard
any other objection
that makes any better sense.
One thing that I think,
individually, librarians
and archivists sometimes worry
about-- and museums, too--
is if we digitize
it, people will stop
coming to the physical space.
And I actually, as
a library director,
found exactly the opposite.
When we digitize things,
people wanted to come.
They wanted to come and see
the objects and touch them
and so forth.
And I actually think
that's the better argument
is make these things
available more broadly
and encourage people to
interact with them in ways
that are really productive.
And I actually
think that if we did
a large-scale empirical study,
that's what would happen.
And you think about it.
You all work in
the digital space.
I think people get
on airplanes more
because they want to be
face to face or drink beer
or have a coffee with somebody
when you meet them online.
So I actually think
in both of those ways,
those objections are false.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Actually, expanding on
that last point you just made,
you presented a very romantic
view of a lot of library spaces
in this talk and
meanwhile talked
a lot about digitizing
a lot of these works.
And I'm just wondering why
libraries should continue
as a physical space--
what you think
justifies that-- as opposed to,
as you just suggested, almost
turning them into a museum where
someone could come and interact
with something they saw online.
JOHN PALFREY: That's
a wonderful point.
And I guess that's
partly what I'm
trying to say with this book
is I think both are valuable.
There is a value of having
public, open, accessible
third spaces that don't happen
to be a Starbucks or McDonald's
or owned by a company.
There's nothing
wrong with Starbucks.
I've frequented it myself.
But I do think that in
communities we need spaces
where people come and are joined
around ideas and knowledge.
You could make an argument that
libraries could just as well
be, say, community centers.
I don't make that argument.
I actually think
that if libraries
were to become just
community centers,
you would miss something.
So I think it's about
the physical space,
it is about the coming together,
it is about the other humans
who are there-- whether they're
the patrons or the librarians.
But it's also about the
ideas and the knowledge
in an important way.
And I think that
romanticism is really
deeply connected to
an active democracy
and an act of being a citizen.
On the other side, I think if
we let that argument-- saying
librarians have no
role or libraries have
no role in a digital era-- I
think that means we're going
to lose those physical space.
Why?
Just because of the number of
times-- and you've probably
had this discussion-- in
communities when you're trying
to decide whether money goes to
fire or to police or to schools
or to administrators or
any of the other things
that are competing,
if you don't make
a good argument for libraries--
and, in fact, people just
say I can get what
I want an Amazon
or get what I want
on Google-- I think
we will lose those
essential spaces.
I think, though, if
we allow nostalgia
to be the driver--
in other words,
that memory of what
a library was-- I
think that will erode over time.
I think the idea
has to be something
that creates new nostalgia.
It creates new ideas and
new excitement around what
a library can be and
will be the basis
on which we will continue
to reinforce this very
powerful public option.
So I think it's a great point.
AUDIENCE: I have a
multi-part question.
JOHN PALFREY: Awesome.
No surprise at Google Cambridge.
AUDIENCE: Also, I've been
working on Google Book Search
for over seven years now.
My wife worked in acquisitions
at the Harvard Business School
Library before we met and
my father was a printer.
And my mother was a bookseller.
JOHN PALFREY: You have the
entire industry covered.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Metadata, I applaud
your drive there.
This is mostly just a comment.
I didn't work on metadata
directly as Francis did.
But the metadata availability
is a mess, and I'm all for it
getting homogenized.
I'm glad there's an open
project like this to do it.
JOHN PALFREY: Why do
you think it's a mess?
I agree, I'm just curious.
AUDIENCE: We have a bookstore--
Google Playbooks is now
what it's called-- we discovered
that the Great Gatsby showed up
as a computer book.
And we dug into the metadata--
OCLC is where they came from.
Amazon also showed it like that.
But because people weren't
buying it as a computer book,
that bit of metadata was so
buried down that no one ever
found it on Amazon that way.
But it showed up when we put
a shelf of computer books up.
And when this happens, when
a book like the Great Gatsby
has the genre
computer programming
or whatever was associated with
it, you know there's a problem.
It's hard to correct.
You're going through
a central organization
that tries to get the original
provider of the data to fix it.
So much of the data
comes from things
scribbled on cards
that were later
typed in by low wage workers.
I heard a story-- I will not
name individuals involved--
where someone
working in a library
came across a second bar
code associated with the book
and thought, oh, this must be a
mistake and was deleting them.
And it turned out they
were essential information.
It was just assumed
by this hourly worker
to be irrelevant, a
mistake, and deleted.
And the pencil scratches and
pen markings on the paper card
catalog cards, you can imagine
all sorts of transcription
errors by somebody
who isn't a librarian
and doesn't understand and
even some from the librarians.
So getting the
metadata such that it
isn't swimming upstream for any
organization to try to keep it
ordered.
Recovering from
metadata that is here
is an item on the
shelf that has a card
and, instead, here is an
entity described on the card
that maybe half a dozen
different editions
on the shelves,
some of which are in
multi-book bound volumes and
some of which are individual.
The clustering problem.
We've been spending years
on it, and it is still
very much an ongoing battle.
And it's a problem that
needs to be solved so that we
can wrap our culture
around these books
and find the ones that
people are looking
for when they go looking.
Librarians-- one of the
auxiliary uses of librarians
is you walk into a library
and you ask how do I find out
what buses run downtown?
And a librarian, being a
general knowledge assistant,
you might say, can say
either we have something
in the library
about that or here's
a phone number I believe if
you called you'd find out.
A lot of people who need
the information the most
are the ones who were
isolated from information.
Maybe you're at home--
like was Matilda the name
with the family that just
watched TV and didn't read
books-- and you don't
have a good place
to ask general questions.
Google and Bing and
things like that, you
can get some answers that way.
But to get a human-interpreted
question answered
is very difficult.
Libraries and the
librarians, in particular,
I see moving into a realm of
general information assistance
with certain information
resources stored there
where they're available and
other ones they can point you
to the computers.
Computers I think have
become part of libraries
only because it's
a convenient place
to put a town-wide
accessible resource.
So that's how I think
libraries might go
and librarians in particular
and the spaces might go.
Do you have any comment on that?
JOHN PALFREY: I think there is
a plausible future that you're
describing is adjusting the
role the reference library
and of course one of
the subsets of people
who work in libraries.
And I think one part where
I would strongly agree
is that libraries
exist for all of us,
but they are most
important for a subset
of people in our society.
And at least in the context
of big urban environments,
it is enormously
essential for places
who are seeking
jobs, people who are
new immigrants to the country,
people who are learning
to read in a variety of ways.
Very often-- in fact,
in most libraries,
the largest users
are young people.
They are kids who are
coming out of school.
They actually don't have a great
place to go in the afternoon,
and they go to a library
for several hours.
And they have a series of
basic needs, some of which
relate to doing their homework
and sometimes that free Wi-Fi
is the only good
free Wi-Fi they can
get to complete their homework.
And sometimes it is that there
is someone there an adult
who is in their life and
can be a mentor for them.
So I actually think one of
the key reasons for defending
library budgets is to say that
for a lot of purposes that
are fairly broadly
written actually
don't have anything to do with
anything that looks like this.
That's an essential
part in our society.
And is that a policeman?
Not quite.
Is it someone who works in fire?
Someone who works in town hall?
No, there is some
value to people
whose role in the community
is to help people access
the information that they
need to be effective citizens
or to be thriving or
joyful in their society.
So that's a slightly
broader version
of what you're suggesting, but
I think ultimately that's right.
And I don't think it can only
be provided at a distance
through a digital interface.
Now, can you imagine a
group of librarians-- maybe
people who've retired from
librarianship-- spending
time being general
information reference
people through digital
interfaces for someone who
is shut in?
Absolutely.
And actually, I think if you
get this overall interface
right and this overall
platform right, that
could be a wonderful
thing for people to do.
And maybe it's a way
for people, ultimately,
to connect to one another if
you're a retired librarian who
actually isn't mobile
anymore but wants
to participate in an active way.
That's something that actually
can be a very powerful thing
for them to do.
And so it's a
wonderful opening, I
think, to think about what
the role could look like.
AUDIENCE: And
finally, since I don't
see anyone else
waiting for a question,
the elephant in the room.
Copyright, something
that Google has
done that we haven't had
available to libraries-- maybe
it hasn't come up
in the thinking
so much-- is when a
publisher has a book,
if the government
says you have to make
it available to
everyone electronically,
you can't keep it
locked down as long
as they're looking at one
page every 10 seconds.
The publishers are going to,
of course, be up in arms.
It's very hard to
convince something
like that to go through
when they could potentially
lose a lot of the
profit that motivates
them to publish this books.
And if it's not available,
if it's only metadata,
then we lose a lot of the
value of libraries potentially.
Google does like
10% to 20% preview.
Is that the sort of thing that
now that technology enables
it you folks are considering
it as a way to advocate
for greater book availability?
JOHN PALFREY: Sure.
I mean, is that a good thing?
It absolutely is.
And can we find the
version of fair use
that is maximally able to
make books more accessible?
Totally.
I'm completely in favor of it.
AUDIENCE: Just to
clarify, that is not
our view of fair use or
implementation of fair use.
That is our implementation of
we put a clause in the contract
with the rights owner that
would allow us to do that.
JOHN PALFREY: Thank you.
This is recorded
and put on YouTube
and you have your own
legal interpretation.
My legal interpretation is
you can do that under fair use
and it's great you have
that nice contract clause.
So increasingly,
I think we ought
to try things that do press
what the boundaries of fair use
are in a positive way.
And I ultimately
think that there
are ways that the authors
like myself and publishers
to publish these books
will get amply compensated
in this digital environment.
I think there's going to be a
huge amount of experimentation
with business models going
to that first question.
And a little bit of
that is happening now.
And I think more will
happen over time.
I think very specifically--
to get slightly geeky
on copyright law-- I
think section 108 ought
to be amended, which is
the special set of things
that allow libraries to
make things available.
I think there are ways to think
about it quite differently.
Also for disabled people
it's a very important element
of things.
I think adjusting
the orphan works
rule would be the obvious
and almost stupidest rule
out there in the
sense that if somebody
has a work that where you don't
actually know who the copyright
holder is, the fact that
the default is that we can't
actually digitize it and
make it available in order
to let that person come to
the form, it is amazing.
Who benefits from not changing
the orphan works rules?
Nobody.
So I think there are
a whole pile of things
that we could do that are really
blindingly obvious and helpful.
Is it OK to take
one more, Brendan?
One more.
Yes, ma'am?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was just curious
if you have comments
on the population of
people who are librarians
and whether the ones we now
have the right kinds of skills
and interests to help
build this thing.
Whether the librarian
education now
is teaching the
right sort of stuff.
And are the people coming
through that now interested
in having the same
kinds of roles
as current librarians have?
JOHN PALFREY: It's
a great question,
and it's an important
one, ultimately.
And I think for those who wring
their hands about the future
of libraries, often
the critique is
saying we have an aging
population of librarians who
actually don't really
think about the future.
And our library schools are not
training people for the things
we actually need to get done.
And is there some
argument there?
Of course there's
an argument there.
That's not my
experience, though,
having worked in libraries.
And I think there is a
very large pivot going on.
And I think that
pivot involves people
who are incredibly
devoted to ensuring
the future of libraries figuring
out a role for librarians
the does bring the digital
into the environment.
It doesn't throw away the good
things that are being done.
I think the hard part is,
honestly, making trade offs
and saying we actually don't
need to do that anymore
or that old rule about only five
elements of metadata in a world
in which there's much
more available-- things
have to go the way
of the dodo bird
and the horse and
buggy and all the rest
and have to be replaced with
things that are wonderful.
So my concern is actually
just the rate at which
that shift is happening.
And when people say, oh, people
aren't moving to digital books
so much.
They're still focused
on physical books,
and we still love libraries
and whatever, I just
fear that those are just
two thin reeds to cling to.
The world is changing vastly
more quickly than that.
I actually think that many
libraries schools are now
called information
schools or I-schools.
Many of the faculty
in those schools
absolutely see what's going on.
And I think that's
only a good thing.
But I think there's
a huge amount
to be done, which would take
the excitement and the things
that you all do in digital
technology environments
and bring that much
more into libraries.
And that's why I'm excited about
things like the Digital Public
Library of America
effort because I think
it says all the stuff that built
the web and the internet and so
forth, those same principles,
those same skills,
those can make amazing things
happen in the public interest.
And lots of people are
doing it, but lots of people
are doing it in for-profits
that actually do great things.
But too few are doing it in the
context of R&D in libraries.
And I think that's why I'd love
to see more of a shift toward.
But do I think that the people
who are working in libraries
are amazing and forward looking?
Absolutely.
Thank you so much for having
me here at Google Cambridge.
I'm very grateful.
[APPLAUSE]